there was a
incident between johnny and amber
here during that trip can you please
describe that incident johnny was
in the office up here
and he was agitated kind of walking back
and forth i'd asked him if he needed
anything because i figured i wasn't sure
why if he was up here to get something
or was looking for something and amber
came in and she was asking him to
tell him to come back to the house
please come back i'm sorry come back
and
he
stood
stood here reluctant to go um didn't
want to go
and um he will exchange back and forth
he
left the office and got into his vehicle
and started it up and amber went outside
and stood in front of the vehicle
um so that
didn't drive away she was standing and
amber was standing in front of it and um
again it was she was asking him to don't
leave i'm sorry come back to the house
after a couple minutes
she got in the vehicle and they left to
go up back to their house
what happened after they went back up to
the house
um cj and i were still in the office and
um weren't really sure
decided that maybe it would be best if
we just drove up there just to make sure
that
everything was okay
you could hear them and you can hear
them inside you could hear inside the
house
yelling
um
her amber yelling and and johnny
answering back and you could really hear
what was being said
um we stood there for a couple minutes
uh cj myself and then um
then you started to hear um it became
audible um amber was telling him that he
was a
washed-up actor
he was gonna die a lonely uh fat lonely
old man
then you heard uh you hit me with a can
you hear johnny say you hit me with a
can and then he came down the steps
and amber was behind him
and she had a
bottle in her hand it was removed and
there was a brief pause the moment uh i
think of initial shock or
uncertainty of why you know that we were
there they need neither johnny nor amber
knew that we were there
um he proceeded to
walk back to the john deere
and um
she
again walked he was sitting in the seat
each amber came up to him and was asking
him to come back in the house that she
was sorry please come back in the house
um
and uh
he didn't come out of the seat and she
was hugging and kissing him and i love
you i love you she was telling him i
loved you
um he didn't react
johnny sat there
eventually uh got out of the john deere
um and proceeded to
start to walk away at that time amber
started to grab at him and his shirt and
trying to pull him back to the house
just basically viciously trying to pull
him back and and get him back in the
house and and and yelling at him and at
that point i was between them and uh
felt it was
best and i was getting worried about
what was going to happen and it was best
that um
[Music]
i remove him from the
situation and so um cj took
amber back to the house and i
walked johnny over to the cafe which was
basically 30 seconds away from from the
house because it was the only place i
could take him to at the time
and you mentioned that miss heard was
viciously trying to pull mr depp back
can you explain what you mean by that
um
it was like clawing grabbing in his
clothes grabbing his hair trying to like
pull him back like an angry like he was
leaving and come back he couldn't leave
in the vehicle because the keys had been
taken out
so there was there wasn't a way for
johnny to drive away the only way was
for
him to to what for him to walk away and
um
it
wasn't
a pleasant situation of of wanting him
to
to not leave and um
angry and yelling and just yelling you
know come back come back don't leave
um and things like that
at any point did mr depp um
hit or touch miss heard objection
leading
all right same objection
miss roberts um how did mr depp react to
miss heard viciously grabbing him
he he didn't uh he stood there with his
arms by his side and um
he
he didn't do anything